the harder it is to afford things the
harder it is to get child care the
harder the more expensive it is to go to
school
the more people are going to be open to
the argument that these things cost too
much the only way you're going to be
able to have it is that the government
provides it for you and so once the
government begins the government doesn't
just take over early childhood education
it decides when it takes it over what's
being taught and who gets to teach it it
doesn't just take over higher education
it decides what you have to teach and
who gets to go it doesn't just take over
when it sends you a check in the mail
every month you know it doesn't
just decide how much money you have in
the bank it makes you dependent on that
program continuing and having to
increase taxes on other people in order
for the money to be there to do that so
in many ways i think this inflation is
an example and even the supply chain
shortages
create a scenario in which people they
think or become more open to becoming
dependent on government to fill in their
needs because the economy can't do it
only government can do it and that's the
fundamental argument they're making
right is that these are important things
in life
private economy cannot provide it for
you cannot provide you the security only
government can but that always comes at
the price of your freedom and liberty
both economic and personal
is that our biggest problem outside of
our borders that if if we don't do
anything nobody else will and sort of
after 20 years of failed nation building
like the american people as you said
people don't want well they certainly
don't want a ground war i don't think
they want any sort of war i don't want a
war i don't want a nation build but i
understand we do have
a unique place in the world and if we're
not the ones kind of saying bad guys you
can't always do whatever you want to do
it's like then all bets are off
yeah look i mean if you're going to be a
country as big and as powerful with an
economy as advanced as ours then what
happens around the world is going to
matter to you because you're sourcing
products you're sourcing raw material
energy
trade commerce
all over the world and so you need there
to be stability the one thing you can
never allow happen for example is let's
say china comes to dominate the
asia-pacific region and so suddenly we
can't trade we just lost all those
countries in asia that we sell things to
and buy things from
we have to deal with china and they
decide what to sell or buy from us so a
lot of that's really domestic like we
have to have an industrial capability in
this country we have to have the ability
you cannot be a great power if you're
not in industrial power i i don't care
what people tell you you can't just be
the place that invents things on paper
and then ships it off for someone else
to make it eventually the people making
these things are the people that will
invent them and not to mention the
national security ramifications of it so
number one we have to be industrial
power number two we have to make sure
that we don't live in a world in which a
great power dominates a region and
basically we have no access to people
that want to trade in commerce with us
that said that has to be balanced
against the notion of over extension
there are a lot of bad things that
happen in the world we need to speak
about it and do what we can but most of
them do not have an american military
solution nor should they in terms of us
getting involved and overextending
ourselves our number one priority must
always be the national interest of our
country and and and um and protecting it
from uh from threats uh both at home and
our interests around the world and it's
like it's a balance that that's that you
have to pull off in public policy but
but to your greater point about no one
else will do it i think a lot of times
what happens is if america isn't
involved then some people will get
involved but they're going to get
involved in ways that may not
necessarily further our national
interests uh the withdrawal from
afghanistan for example has led a lot of
countries in the middle increasingly
turned to china and russia
as their uh defense
partner preference and and that that's
concerning because that could mean for
the future
of american uh economic prosperity and
security
do you think some of this is sort of by
design like when you see the way a guy
like say bill de blasio kind of wrecked
new york city which is just an absolute
disaster a place that i lived most of my
adult life before moving to l.a you know
people are like oh you know he this is
an accident like these policies he
didn't realize what was going to happen
but he just gave a speech a couple days
ago where it's like oh no this was great
it's all it's all great here and i feel
the sort of similar way with biden it's
like i don't know that he really thinks
things aren't going well now you look at
the shelves and you look at people's
jobs and everything else and you clearly
realize the price of gas the price of
food etc you realize things aren't but
do you think some of it is actually by
design that it's it's a feature not a
bug in a way of the way they govern
both i think it's the natural
consequence of these decisions they
always lead to disaster but i also don't
think that i think they're not
necessarily overly troubled by it
inflation's a great example inflation if
you believe that you want marxism
socialism and you want the government to
control more of our economy
then inflation isn't necessarily a bad
thing because the way you view it is the
more expensive life gets right the
harder it is to afford things the harder
it is to get child care the harder the
more expensive it is to go to school
the more people are going to be open to
the argument that these things cost too
much the only way you're going to be
able to have it is that the government
provides it for you and so once the
government begins the government doesn't
just take over early childhood education
it decides when it takes it over what's
being taught and who gets to teach it it
doesn't just take over higher education
it decides what you have to teach and
who gets to go it doesn't just take over
when it sends you a
check in the mail
every month you know it doesn't just
decide how much money you have in the
bank it makes you dependent on that
program continuing and having to
increase taxes on other people in order
for the money to be there to do that so
in many ways i think this inflation is
an example and even the supply chain
shortages
create a scenario in which people they
think or become more open to becoming
dependent on government to fill in their
needs because the economy can't do it
only government can do it and that's the
fundamental argument they're making
right is that these are important things
in life
private economy cannot provide it for
you cannot provide you the security only
government can but that always comes at
the price of your freedom and liberty
both economic and
personal yeah and that's what i mean
about feature not a bug it's like a guy
like de blasio he wrecked new york city
but in his view it's like oh but the
government's doing more now so thus this
is good and i think that that's sort of
what's going on all over the place so to
that point obviously there's midterms
coming you know everybody's talking
about some some big red
wave or something i'm pretty sure we're
going to be safe here
in florida do you by the way do you say
florida or florida i'm a new yorker
originally so i say florida you say
everyone's else saying florida here but
i also say orange juice not orange juice
so i don't know no no one's ever i mean
i've heard about nevada and nevada but
i've never heard of florida in florida i
don't know what i say florida
i don't know you say florida i say
florida i people are telling me it's in
new york there we say florida we say
orange instead orange but what do you
what do you think is going to happen in
in this midterm situation i mean do you
think we can actually capture i mean we
i never would have said we before but i
think it's we at this point uh you know
get the house back it sounds like the
senate's gonna do pretty well and what
do you what do you say well the easiest
way to lose at anything is to think is
to act like you're winning so i think
that's the first thing we have to keep
in mind the second is i mean
these guys raise a lot of money okay as
an example right chuck schumer went out
and hand-picked val demings the
congresswoman from central florida was
just a puppet of nancy pelosi and said
that's who i want to be our candidate in
florida and she's raising i don't know
10 million dollars a quarter or more
online just sending out an email so
they're going to raise that kind of
money for candidates i mean every senate
republican incumbent was outraged in in
2020 and in 2018. so we can't overlook
the fact that these people are going to
outraise us we're also not going to get
any benefit from media as a perfect
example okay i was ranked the most
effective republican senator by the
vanderbilt university of virginia
program that looks at the effectiveness
of members of congress another group
again nonpartisan ranked me the second
number two in leadership score passed a
bunch of really meaningful bills not the
least of which was the creation of the
paycheck protection program that
literally saved millions of small
business jobs in this country you
wouldn't know that i mean
a week ago a couple weeks ago it was my
work and having to blow up the defense
bill that got
forced nancy pelosi in the house to pass
a bill that banned the import of
products made by uyghur slave laborers
none of that stuff is reported on the
media is is a real challenge for us
because they're not we're we're they're
not going to report on our
accomplishments or accurately in many
cases to put out what we're working on
or what our position is on these issues
and uh so so i wouldn't take that for
granted either so these guys are going
to have more money and they're gonna
have the benefit of mainstream media so
we're gonna have to work real hard to
make sure that our base knows what's
going on that people turn out and vote
do i feel good about the direction of
florida do i feel good about the fact
that people are realizing joe biden is a
disaster absolutely but we but the
election isn't today it's in november
we've got a long ways to go between now
and then we've got to make sure that
people keep learning not just about what
they're doing wrong but what we're going
to do right if they give us the chance
to be in the position of controlling the
senate and house if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell